[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show as
always it is powered by icon plus so a
really quick news announcement for you
so
korea's largest mobile phone provider
denial fintech
will actually support icx as payment
method this year and launch a prepaid
crypto card
with china's union pay so really
exciting there
now this is sponsored by blockbuy you
can get up to 8.6
interest on your usdc and it is also um
sponsored by coinflip so i will leave a
link you can get um
a discount code so i'll leave that
scrolling at the bottom in a minute now
if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like
button and hit subscribe because you
never want to miss
any of these fantastic guests now let's
jump straight into this because joining
me today is the founder of the global
alternative investment firm skybridge
capital
and salt conference and he worked
famously as the white house
communications director under president
trump in 2017 for just
11 days i'm sure you can guess who it is
it is anthony
scaramucci how are you doing today well
at least you got the time right you know
some people say 10 days
later and it hurts my feelings so i
appreciate you
mentioning the last day of course in the
last days the one i
probably the most famous for this one
where i got fire summarily fired
so how are you i'm good thank you i'm
good how are you doing thanks for
joining me
no i'm i'm terrific uh it's a it's a big
uh
it's big opportunity right now in the
crypto space obviously
there's uh lots of things going on and
uh lots of institutions are joining
so uh i'm super excited about that yeah
it's pretty insane and i do want to jump
into all of that but
before we do um i messaged you before
the interview and i asked you is
anything off limits
and you told me no you told me no no
nothing's off limits of course now why
would there be anything
off limits that's not fun i love it cool
so before we jump into bitcoin then um i
do want to just
jot back to 2017. can you give us a
brief overview of what happened
and why you would only um the comms
director for only 11 days not 10 but 11.
well well i'm well i i have to probably
take you back to 2016 then to apply
context i was i i was a lifetime
republican party fundraiser uh mr trump
was running for office
uh none of us took it seriously i was
working for jeb bush
jeb came out of the race mr trump
recruited me
uh i made many colossal mistakes but my
first one was accepting his invitation
to join his campaign
we then won the presidency which seemed
very unlikely on november the 8th
election day 2016
but then further to complicate things he
wins and then he names me
to his 16 person executive
transition team so i was one of 16
people on his executive transition
committee
picking the cabinet interviewing under
secretaries and so forth and then
he offered me a job the original job was
to be
in the networking area of the white
house which is called the
liaison department so the it's sort of
like a
global liaison coordinator rice priebus
and steve bannon
two of my nemesis they didn't want me in
that job i didn't realize at the time
how cutthroat
i thought wall street was cutthroat
layla until i got to washington
i tell my buddies on wall street i want
you to imagine the worst person that
you've ever met on wall street that is
the best person in washington i mean
we're a bunch of babies on wall street
compared to these people
and so when they went to cut my throat i
got myself
in a little bit of a bind i let my pride
get the better of me
i went to mr trump then president trump
and said these are two bad guys if you
want to get rid of them
uh invite me back and i'll come and do
that and so he invited me in six months
later
to be the coms director i was ill-suited
for that job even though i
can present on television i don't really
have communications experience in dc
should have never taken that job but i
took it
and then the fight started we had a
shootout at the okay corral between me
and reince priebus and steve bannon
i said something really funny uh but
very important
well i don't want to say it on your show
i mean you guys can google it but i said
something about steve
bannon and something that he was capable
of doing to himself
anatomically which if you know anything
about steve bannon and his girth and the
fact that he doesn't do hot yoga
uh you know he probably couldn't do what
i said uh and a result of which the
report
reporter recorded that and reported it
on cnn
john kelly the chief of staff fired me
for those remarks
deservedly so uh and so i think i made
those remarks on day eight i think i was
fired on day 11
and so my what's the lesson there is
take accountability for your mistakes i
made a mistake
i got fired never blamed anybody for it
and you know was
also trying to be helpful to the
administration and the republican party
after my firing no no villains there
no victims i take total responsibility
for my firing but
prior to those 11 days and for the last
33 years less those 11 days i've been
a money manager an investment manager
since i left law school
i started at goldman sachs i built a
company
after i left goldman sold it
successfully and then started skybridge
16 short years ago and so that's really
what i've been doing for most of my life
so
when they're trying to cancel you this
is a learning lesson for people that
watch your show
they're trying to cancel you if you're
an entrepreneur it's very hard to get
cancelled because
they fired me i dusted myself off and
went back to work at my own company
yeah council culture is rife right now
um i can even i can even tell you it's
kind of rife within the
bitcoin community i had some cancelling
of myself yesterday it was it was quite
the learning curve
who's trying to cancel you leia the ceo
was one bitcoin he canceled me yesterday
so we'll we'll just get that one out
there
maybe he'll get over it we're in a rough
we're in a rough environment
i don't take myself that seriously uh
here's my thanos cup in case you need
somebody
to see that i mean why take yourself
that seriously and just remember
in the immortal wars of mel brooks the
95 year old american comedian relax
none of us are getting out of here alive
so try not to take things too seriously
no i totally agree with you um but
speaking of not taking yourself too
seriously that is something that uh
good old donald trump never did so he's
a bit of a controversial character so
i do want to get into bitcoin but before
we do i do want to get like a brief
understanding of what he's like to work
with because
i watched some interviews and you sort
of played off this
character that's and that's not
empathetic but at the same time is
deeply sensitive
um to criticism and ridicule so what
kind of character is he like you know i
it's not personal my uh
my decision to break away from mr trump
and my decision not to
back him in the 2020 election really not
personal it's an evaluation so
let me just put it to you this way let's
say the two of us were on the board of a
publicly traded company either
in the uk or the united states we had to
pick a ceo we had selection criteria
but unfortunately we're only down to two
choices and so we can only pick these
two people to be the ceo of our company
uh and we chose donald trump and then
donald trump had
several years where he was operating as
ceo and he was manifesting himself in
the way that he did
through his twitter account the
generosity of his rhetoric the insanity
of his hiring and firing process
uh then you and i would have to say as
responsible board members this is not
uh good this is ill-suited to be
uh that ceo and then of course once
again you only have two choices
so you have to choose between the
existing ceo i think is an object
failure
or potentially somebody else and so you
could also
be a failure possibly but i don't think
so i think he's doing a pretty good job
i mean
yeah he's six weeks into it he's uh he's
a calm
guy i'm sorry bomb syria already
he bombed syria already yeah you know
the in the united states whether people
like this or not uh is going to probably
protect its interests militarily around
the world now people can like that
or dislike it but it's a fairly
bipartisan thing whether it's barack
obama
more drone strikes in the first three
years than the bush administration's
eight years
uh whether it's a left-leaning political
administration or right-leaning
political organization
it's likely going to protect its
interests militarily overseas
irrespective you could like or dislike
that i'm just being observant about that
uh if you want my opinion about it i'm
happy to share it but that's really
uh uh something that's gonna happen
that's an axiomatic fact of uh
american pop foreign policy whether
people like that or not
but uh listen he's not donald trump and
so he's not offering this insanity on
twitter
i think john kelly uh the gentleman that
fired me who i developed a very close
relationship to
uh says it better than anybody and i'll
quote from him
you don't realize how crazy donald trump
is until you're inside that one degree
orbit
of his space once you're inside that
space and you're operating alongside of
him
you're like okay wait a minute this
guy's ill-suited to be president he
doesn't have the
personality makeup or the integrity
or the bandwidth towards things like uh
empathy emotion
and things like that to really be the
president so
i made a mistake we move on but you're
asking me about him i'll tell you about
him he's
a very complex wounded guy uh he's
remarkably
insecure uh i guess i didn't see that
when he was
in his area of competence which is being
a rock on tour a radio
television reality host but when he was
put
in the position of the head of state of
the world's most powerful military
and one of the world's most powerful
economies
you got to see the manifestation of his
full-blown insecurity and so he couldn't
handle people around him
that may have had expertise and or
opinion that was more sophisticated than
his
he tried to steamroll those people or in
the immortal words of
general mcmaster who served as his
second national
security adviser he always was
counter-intuitive which was a way of
saying i'm too insecure to hear your
opinion so i'm going to steamroll you so
very ineffective as a leader failed the
country 13 million jobs lost during his
four-year
term he made the country sicker he
mishandled and malpracticed on the
pandemic
we had 670 deaths per million in the
united states over the last year
compared to a place like south korea
where there were only 20 million
sorry only 20 deaths per million in
south korea so we did 30 times worse
than a country like south korea due to
mismanagement of covet 19.
uh he's an abject liar 34 000 lies were
told during that period of time
he weakened our alliances not only the
alliance with the uk
but i would say just about every
alliance that we built since the
end of the world war war ii
he praised despots and dictators
and people that subject their
populations to a lack of freedom
and he denigrated democratic leaders
so i think all in all uh i'm relieved to
see him go
and i'll be around to make sure he
doesn't come back
wow some really strong opinions um i
have some i think i'm holding back
you know i haven't had my coffee yet you
know i'm i'm drinking hot and cold
that's you holding back yeah but i think
i'm holding back a little bit you know
i have a tendency to be fairly shy and
reserved
so i'm just holding okay while holding
back here
if we had more time i'd debate this with
you because i think it's a pretty
interesting one but i want to just kind
of move a little bit
let's have the debate so it's apparently
you like him uh have you ever met him
no it's not that i like him i'm just
less of a fan of biden that's all like
i'm i'm less of a fan of him
you're saying that uh uh president i
understand
that the lessons
you got to do more homework interview
more people yeah you got to interview
more people that were in mr trump's
inner circle
so that you could see his full-blown
psychosis
and you can see his full-blown lack
of empathy his full-blown incapability
of making good decisions his lack of
executive management and functioning
skills
and the fact that he's a sociopath uh
whatever you think of uh
president biden he's not a sociopath and
so i think
uh you know i'm interested in making
money and taking care of my family and
protecting the people i love
i would prefer not to have a sociopath
uh sitting on top of the world's most
powerful military so no i'd be very
happy to have that i got you
you i would love to have it with anybody
thank god 81 million people in the
united states agree with me
and by the way uh you know despite what
i'm saying mr trump almost won that
election
it was only a 71 000 vote differential
among those battleground states
i'd love to debate it with you but i
cannot because i know we have a time cap
on this
and i do want to talk about bitcoin
because that's the most interesting
thing right now
at the moment trump is old news um right
so
okay kind of moving on from that biden
um is gonna pump one point um what is it
nine trillion
into uh the us economy so we've seen a
crazy amount of money printing over the
last
year with the whole pandemic so i just
want to get your perspective on that
and how you think that's gonna affect
the us dollar and then we'll kind of
move into bitcoin
well i think it's important to give a
little bit more of a historical
allegory so that you can understand why
we're in bitcoin
and also why we're so bullish on bitcoin
and i'm going to take you back to 1944
to bretton woods new hampshire and in
as the world was beginning the process
of entering the post-world war ii era
and what to do with the industrial
economy some of which were damaged in
the war
uh the economists leaders
people from trade around the world
trade associations etc got to bretton
woods and made some decisions
and what was clear whether you were a
liberal economist or a conservative
economist what was clear
was that we wanted something and we
wanted a term that we never use anymore
layla
it is a purchasing power parity
and so what the economist said if we
want to promote global trade and peace
and prosperity
and raise living standards the
currencies
the global currencies have to be in a
trading band
we can't let any of these industrial
nations manipulate their currencies i.e
cheapen their currencies on a relative
basis so that they can
increase their exports and so if you go
back to bretton woods
i think it's very very important because
over that 27 year period where
bretton woods held you had tremendous
economic growth
very high prosperity numbers per capita
and you had rising living standards and
a rising middle class
in 1971 the united states made a
decision to break from bretton woods
and unclip the u.s dollar from the gold
standard
and so just so everybody understands
that 35 an ounce for gold 1971
17 or so hundred dollars an ounce today
we crushed the us dollar we took it from
uh reasonably good purchasing power
to a full monetization and so let me
just give that number
two u.s dollars two u.s dollars
in 1971 have 100
of 20 21 dollars of purchasing power so
you know we we
crushed the u.s dollar during that
period of time china manipulated its
currency as well which helped them
become a mercantilist
expert economy and in 2008
we flooded the system with u.s dollars
to prop up the system after the global
financial crisis so satoshi nakamoto
or those people that are known as
hitachi nakamoto
refined digital currencies there were
several
digital currencies but they they got it
almost perfectly right with bitcoin and
they sent it into the marketplace they
developed a white paper which i
recommend to everybody that they read
and he basically explained if we don't
get back to some kind of standardized
currency for the world
we are jeopardizing living standards
around the world and that is true in the
uk
and in the united states so after the
introduction of bitcoin
12 years later the united states has
pumped and devalued its dollar
but so has the british central bank
and so had the european central bank and
there has been global
central banking coordination to monetize
debt and to flow tremendous amounts
of dollar production or currency
production around the world
that helps rich people it hurts poor
and middle-class people and it's
manifested itself
in nationalism it's manifested itself in
populism
and it's led to the rise of political
leaders failed political leaders i might
say but the rise of them like donald
trump
and so this time around with the
pandemic
because we have weak political
leadership in the west and no one wants
to develop an industrial policy
a manufacturing policy an education
policy they just want to be solely
reliant on monetary policy we're
producing more dollars
to try to solve this problem in the last
six
months the volume of money supply in the
united states is
up 26 percent so i just want to stop and
have everybody take a look at that
we have 26 percent more dollars produced
in the last six months
than we had in the prior 244 years
if the stimulus that you referenced
earlier goes through
the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
we will have 40 percent that's another
increase in dollar volume you'll have 40
percent so where is it going to show up
it's going to show up in
asset prices expense of real estate
collectibles uh things like that
but where it's not showing up is in
wages it's not showing up in middle and
lower middle income
uh real income and so can you talk can
you can you talk more just about that
point because
because i actually was talking about the
other day and i sort of said i i think
you know a healthier way to stimulate an
economy is to lower taxes rather than
and print more money
and somebody had mentioned if you print
more money then how will people you know
well if you lower taxes people don't
have money
to pay basically so what
what i'm saying is if you're listening
you could you could expand the earned
income
tax credit the ebit and so what could
happen is
at a certain number you're making money
in
in your job where you're not paying any
taxes so
could that be 50 70 80 dollars and all
of a sudden
you're increasing the living standards
for the bottom part of the pie
yes but i think that the point that
someone was probably pushing back on you
with
is with 27 million people out of work
born from the pandemic if they're not
making any money
doing that doesn't really help them
because you know
but like you said yeah like you said
printing money doesn't exactly create
jobs for
the poor no you know you wouldn't
if you if you were really thinking about
a way to help the poor
uh you would have to have at the
intersection the united states and the
uk
have been at its best when there's an
intersection between
public spending and the private sector
economy
that happened after world war two
as an example in the u.s 16 million
people service men and women accepted
the gi bill
so they either got money to buy a form
they got money to
participate in a liberal arts education
or an engineering education
at our nation's colleges and it laid the
groundwork for a very burgeoning middle
class
we're doing none of that our bridges
roads and tunnels are in decay
our airports are in decay they look like
third world country
our k through 12 educational system is
very uneven
if you live in a good zip code in the
united states in an affluent area
you can get a good public school
education if you live in a
inner city or with a poor tax base
around the school forget it the kids get
passed from grade to grade and they have
no
real skills of anything they have
remedial math and remedial
reading skills and so this is a downward
shifting
the intelligence of the society and it's
making it harder for those people to get
high wage paying jobs so
you're in a difficult situation
and so it does dovetail into bitcoin
because
that white paper which was a brilliant
piece is basically suggesting that if
you can
scale a decentralized monetary network
you will put to rest the policy
whimsy of politicians and so
you know obviously what is the opposite
of a central bank a
decentralized network and so that
network is scaling
uh there's a hundred plus million users
today for bitcoin
by 2025 there could be a billion users
and if we're right at skybridge capital
if our economic team is right
michael saylor is right and others what
you will see is a full-blown
decentralized monetary network
and in many ways that will help the
world not hurt the world
the central bankers are threatened by it
right now but if they really study it
they'll recognize
going back to a bretton woods like
construct
is better for the world there's more
fairness if we have purchasing power
parity
and governmental policy makers or
politicians in
their respective states are not trying
to manipulate
the manufacturing and export game to
benefit them
and so hopefully that can happen uh it's
happening
uh whether people are gonna jump in i'm
gonna jump in though
i i just want to go back though because
like when did you when did you first
hear about bitcoin and what was it about
bitcoin as opposed to
the other cryptocurrencies you know like
if for example
that made you think yeah i want to
dedicate an entire fund to that
i kind of want to like if you can bullet
point maybe like the three or four
biggest things other than
decentralization that really kind of
made sense to you so uh introduced to
bitcoin in 2013 by 2014
it's 400 a coin i'm an institutionalist
i know i can't
sell that product to my clients because
it's not fully scaled
so bitcoin needed three things to have
happen for us to get involved
one it had to continue to adopt
on the scale of metcalfe's law and grow
the network exponentially it has done
that
two it needed to be regulated or taxed
in the united states it's taxed as an
intangible
it's not yet completely regulated but
that process is happening
i.e there's an etf in canada are now two
etfs in canada
i expect by the end of this year
there'll be an american
etf approved by the sec and then the
third thing
which was super important for skybridge
was storage
you and i both know about the tragedy of
people losing their coins on their
phones
laptops sim cards etc skybridge capital
has a half a billion dollars in bitcoin
uh we have it stored at fidelity in
their digital asset space
it's ring fenced in cold storage so it's
off the grid
and it's protected by fidelity their
team their balance sheet as well as a
an insurance layer from lawyers of
london so if you're going to have
institutional investments in bitcoin
uh you're going to need that type of
protection
why that versus the others this is just
our opinion
bitcoin is the big dog bitcoin
originated 12 years ago
there's been 8 300 crypto competitors to
bitcoin
that bitcoin has slayed you tell me
because i'm just guessing at current
market prices it's roughly 80 percent of
the market share
of crypto assets that's out there and so
that's
evidence to us that it has defeated
the other competitors in the space it's
the big kahuna in the space
and since we're institutionalists and
we're going to have a hard enough time
migrating people to crypto in general
let's start with the biggest one and
let's stay on that for a while
perhaps it'll invite me back in a few
years and we'll have other
cryptocurrencies in our funds or maybe
we'll have
funds specific to those other
cryptocurrencies i don't know
but right now we're going to just stick
with uh bitcoin
so with all of that in mind then um you
know there's this kind of big rivalry
between gold and bitcoin and a lot of
people say that
bitcoin is gold 2.0 so i'd really like
your opinion given your background
why you think people like warren buffett
and peter schiff just can't get on board
with it
well it has to do with fud
right you know the term fear uncertainty
and doubt so we have
fud and then we have fuddy duddies
and so what peter schiff and warren
buffett represent in that space
are fuddy duddies it's hard for me to
quibble with warren buffett
because he's one of the greatest
investors ever
at age 90 however he's looking at the
world a certain way
and that certain way has made him
successful
so far be it for me to be critical of
him however
i'll take your listeners and viewers
back to a seminal buffett story
in 1999 i was present at the
sun valley uh allen and company media
conference
a gentleman by the name of jeff bezos
was making a presentation
related to amazon and he was explaining
that he was not going to focus on
earnings
he was going to borrow and spend money
to scale his network
so that he could become the internet
seller of all things
that was in 1999 mr buffett said okay
that sounds great i'm not a buyer i
don't believe in your story
why don't you believe in my story well i
can't tangibly
price it in net present value of a
discounting
stream of earnings because you're not
going to be making any money
for 10 years and mr bezos said well i
don't want to make any money for 10
years because i want to
expand and grow the footprint mr buffett
said no
uh who's been a better capital allocator
in the last 20 years mr bezos
or mr buffett and so we know that it's
mr bezos
and we know that a ten thousand dollar
investment in amazon
in its initial public offering in may
may 15
of 1997 is now worth 21 million one
hundred and forty thousand dollars
and so so the point being is you can
miss things as an investor and still be
a very successful investor legendary
in mr buffett's case um as it relates to
peter schiff he's stuck
on gold that's part of his business i
like peter
but i think that they are intellectually
not willing to accept
where the world is going and the world
is going digital and people of your
generation frankly
are more comfortable in the digital
world than people that were burning
born in the 1930s 40s or 50s or even
perhaps the 60s
so as the world is changing
certain things are going to be more
valuable than others and i think they're
missing this
because they are fuddy-duddies and
they're not willing to
uh be neurally plastic and adapt
themselves to the new world
yeah i think when somebody makes a
fortune a certain way
they kind of like have that blueprint um
and i think it can be so
hard to adapt and sort of see something
different um i mean
i respect it but i i disagree with it in
this case this is something that's very
obvious to me and it's something that
people should if they're listening buy a
small amount of it
uh don't buy enough of it where it could
ruin your
living standard but buy enough of it
where
uh you have a toll hold in it you'll
learn more about it and you'll be
recognizing that you don't own enough of
it that's michael saylor's line the
first bitcoin is the hardest to buy
but once you own it you're like okay i
don't own enough of it i have to figure
out a way to own more
but that is so true but i don't know
anybody that doesn't agree
every single person always hesitates
before buying the first
and then they just they have to buy more
but you said on cnbc
um that you think bitcoin could get to
100k this year
so i want to get your thoughts on that
and also um given the amount of
institutional
um interest and institutional money just
flowing in
how long really do you sort of see this
bull market going
and how high if you look at other
halving cycles of course this having
cycle
uh completed last may you probably have
another 24
so months related this halving cycle
and usually that's when you get the
upside swings in bitcoin
uh but you have something new happening
right now because of the
amount of users we're in the 100 million
plus user zone
and it's it's edging into a trillion
dollars in terms of its market cap it
got there
a week or two ago it's receded from that
uh you're now scaled it is now is
important for institutional investors
take a look
some of the institutions i've talked to
have said well if i'm not
long bitcoin i'm effectively short it
because it'll be
part of the index and i better make sure
that i i've got some of it if i'm going
to be compared to it
and so that supply demand imbalance i
think will
push bitcoin through a hundred thousand
dollars by the end of the year
remember bitcoin went from last march to
three thousand dollars a coin four
thousand dollars a coin
to forty eight thousand dollars a coin
so it's not that big of a move when you
think about the fact that three million
coins have been lost
there are two-ish million coins left to
be mined
and so let me put this uh supply demand
balance and stork
numbers there are 46 million global
millionaires 46 million there are
probably only
17 or so million bitcoins available
you don't even have enough bitcoin for
each
millionaire in our society to own one
coin
and so if you put it in that context you
can see
that there's going to be heavy supply
demand imbalances a fairly scarce
asset it's a trusted asset now from a
value transfer
perspective because these cryptographs
over that network okay is what people
are looking for
in terms of the certainty of value
transfer
and so it's decentralized you can you
can take it outside of the banking
industry
you can take it outside of the auspices
of all of that onerous regulation it
becomes very compelling
and uh you know i i'm optimistic now
having said that
i said a hundred thousand by a year-end
the fuddy-duddies i was talking to were
like whoa
uh but then when you go on twitter i'm
getting yelled at by people
yeah that's consulting i'm not i'm not
bullish enough so
yeah that's very concerning it's
somewhere i'm somewhere in the middle
we'll get it right
yeah for sure just lastly because i know
we all pushed for time
unfortunately but um tim draper he said
that he believes netflix could be the
next
um major company institution to add
bitcoin to their balance sheet so i
wondered who you thought would be
the next institution to do this
um say it one more time because i i lost
you there for a second
drake draper is bullish on bitcoin yep
yeah but but he said netflix would be
the next institution the next company to
add bitcoin to their balance sheet
so i'm wondering who you think is next
amazon apple
it's a good question i'm not i'm not
sure
um you know somebody asked me point
blank of i thought
apple would add bitcoin to its balance
sheet i
said yes now that i'm going to be 50 50.
it's either going to be yes or no but
the reason
i'm suggesting apple is that they want
to be in the wallet business
they've got a credit card now they're
making it easy for you to use your
credit cards over this
phone and the notion that if they start
to own and understand
bitcoin and we eventually get which i
predict we will
a digital dollar and a digital yuan
uh you have the uh you could have
bitcoin sitting on your phone alongside
of a digital dollar a digital
yuan even your digital share of walmart
if you will
um and so you know you you're you're in
this situation where
um uh apple will likely be somebody that
owns or starts to own bitcoin but
but again i don't have any information
related to that
um i don't i i could see why he's saying
netflix they've got a lot of cash on
their balance sheet
um they're cutting edge enough to look
at it they've made some changes to their
business model several times and so
they're adaptive people
uh take a look at square take a look at
what jack dorsey is doing there
um bitcoin is going to be a part of the
future whether peter schiff likes it or
not or people that don't
bitcoin deniers are going to be
disappointed i'm a bitcoin investor
i was once a bitcoin skeptic that has
become a bitcoin investor
i'm not a bitcoin evangelist i think
that you know
it's not like jesus and moses got
together and had a baby and it happened
to be bitcoin
i'm not a bitcoin evangelist right see
the strengths and weaknesses of bitcoin
uh but i recognize that this is a big
part of our future
and if we're right it could have
exponential growth from here
that i want to take advantage of for
myself and my customers
i want to thank you so much for coming
on um it's been so interesting i do have
so many more questions i want to ask you
so
much appreciate it congratulations on
your show
be well thank you so much take care bye